by this point we have discussed pretty
much everything that is to be said about
individual discrete random variables now
let us move to the case where we're
dealing with multiple discrete random
variables simultaneously and talk about
their distribution as we will see their
distribution is characterized by a so
called joint PMF so suppose that we have
a probabilistic model and on that model
we have defined two random variables x
and y and that we have available their
individual pmf's these pmf's tell us
about one random variable at a time this
tells us about X this tells us about Y
but they do not give us any information
about how the two random variables are
related to each other for example if you
wish to answer this question whether the
numerical values that the two random
variables happen to be equal and what is
the probability of that event you will
not be able to answer this question if
you only know the two individual pmf's
in order to be able to answer a question
of this type we will need information
that tells us what values of X tend to
occur together with what values of Y and
this information is captured in the so
called joint PMF so the joint PMF is
nothing but a piece of notation for an
object that's familiar this is the
probability that when we carry out the
experiment we happen to see random
variable X take on value little X and
simultaneously see that random variable
Y takes on a value little Y this
quantity we indicated with this notation
the letter little P stands for a PMF the
subscripts tell us which random
variables were talking about and finally
this is a function of two arguments
depending on what pair X Y were
interested in we are going to get a
different numerical value for this
probability as an example of a joint PMF
in which the two random variables take
values in a finite set
we might be given a table
of this forum using this table we can
answer questions such as the following
what is the probability that the random
variables x and y simultaneously take
the values let us say 1 & 3 then we look
up in this table and we identify that
it's this probability X takes the value
of 1 and Y takes the value of 3 and
according to this table the answer would
be 2 over 20 now something to notice
about joint pmfs when you add over all
possible pairs x and y this exhausts all
the possibilities and therefore these
probabilities should add to 1 in terms
of this table all the entries that we
have here should add to 1 now once we
have in our hands the joint PMF we can
use it to find the individual PMF of the
random variables x and y and these
individual pmfs are called the marginal
pmfs how do we find them well the joint
PMF tells us everything there is to be
known about the two random variables so
it should contain enough information for
us to answer any kind of question so for
example if we wish to find the
probability that the random variable X
takes the value of 4 we look at all
possible outcomes in which X is equal to
4 and add the probabilities of these
outcomes so in this case it would be 1
over 20 plus 2 over 20 so what we're
doing is that if we're interested in a
specific value of x the probability that
X takes on a specific value we consider
all possible pairs associated with that
fixed X that is we are considering one
column of the PMF and we're adding the
corresponding probabilities so to find
this entry here
say px of three what we need is to add
these terms on that column similarly we
can find the PMF of the random variable
Y so for example the probability that
the random variable Y takes on a value
of let's say 2 can be found as follows
you look at the probabilities of all
pairs associated with this specific Y
and you add over the XS so we fix y to
have a value of 2 and we add over all
pairs in this row so in this example it
would be 1 over 20 plus 3 over 20 plus 1
over 20 finally notice that we are able
to answer the question that got us
motivated in the first place to find the
probability that the two random
variables take equal values we look at
all the outcomes for which the two
random variables indeed take the same
numerical values and we see that it is
this event in this diagram and the
probability of that event is going to be
2 over 20 so in general once we have
available the joint PMF of two random
variables we will be able to answer any
questions regarding probabilities of
events that have to do with these two
random variables how about more than two
random variables it's just a matter of
notation for example we can define the
joint PMF of three random variables and
you can use the same idea for the joint
PMF let's say of five or ten or n random
variables let's just look at the
notation for three there is a
well-defined probability that when we
carry out the experiment XY and Z as
random variables take on certain
specific values so we look at the
probability of that particular triple
and we indicate that probability with
this notation once more the subscripts
tell us which random variables were
talking about and the PMF of course
is going to be a function of this triple
little X little Y little Z because each
triple in general should have a
different probability of course
probabilities must always add to one so
when we consider all triples and we add
their corresponding probabilities we
should get one and finally once we have
the joint PMF we can again recover the
marginal PMF for example to find the
probability that the random variable
takes on a specific value little X we
consider all possible triples in which
the random variable indeed takes that
value little X and then we sum over all
the possible Y's and Z's that could go
together with this particular X in the
same spirit the to find the probability
that these two random variables take on
two specific values we consider all the
possible Z's that could go together with
this XY pair so this way we're ranging
over all outcomes in which X and y take
on these specific values but Z is free
to take any value and so we consider all
those possible values of Z and sum the
corresponding probabilities finally we
can talk about functions of multiple
random variables suppose that we have
two random variables x and y and that we
define a function of them so this
function is of course a random variable
and we can find the PMF of this random
variable if we know the joint PMF of X
and Y so the PMF which is the
probability that the random variable
takes on a specific numerical value
that's the probability that the function
of x and y takes on a specific numerical
value and we can find this probability
by adding the probabilities of all XY
pairs
which XY pairs those XY pairs for which
the value of Z would be equal to this
particular number little Z that we care
about so we collect essentially all
possible outcomes that make this event
to happen and we add the probabilities
of all those outcomes
finally similarly to the case where we
have a single random variable and the
function of it we now can talk about
expected values of functions of two
random variables and there is an
expected value rule that parallels the
expected value rule that we had
developed for the case of a function of
this form the form that the expected
value rule takes is similar and it's
quite natural the interpretation is as
follows with this probability a specific
XY pair will occur and when that occurs
the value of our random variable is a
certain number and the combination of
these two terms gives us a contribution
to the expected value now we consider
all possible XY pairs that may occur and
we sum over all these XY pairs